on a un client important donc je compte
sur vous pour que ce soit
particulièrement en face une belle
soirée
qu'est-ce que je vous ai dit j'ai dit on
se coordonne il y a personne qui
comprend que je joue ma vie moi à chaque
soirée je joue ma vie Jean-Pierre Bacri
quel acteur c'est vrai que ce film voilà
je vois que vous avez été bien renseigné
c'est un film qui m'a touché qui m'a
fait rire il y a d'ailleurs dans les
paroles une formule qu'on a beaucoup
repris c'est on s'adapte parce que
Jean-Pierre Bacri dans ce film là il
arrête pas de dire en permanence quand
on organise en mariage on s'adapte mais
je peux vous dire que quand on organise
les jeux on s'adapte donc voilà c'est un
film qui qui m'a fait sourire et on l'a
on l'a partagé avec les équipes parce
que c'est c'est assez semblable
[Musique]